[Música]
bueno tengo que empezar hablando de mi
abuelo porque ahí empezó todo mi abuelo
era un escultor de memoria y a ciegas él
cerraba los ojos palpaba en el aire las
formas los recovecos
asperezas y ya una vez que tenía listo
ese contenido etéreo esa escultura
efímera entonces se volcaba como loco al
barro y hacia su escultura
y entonces yo le decía abuelo pero cómo
es posible que hayas hecho esto era una
copia era una copia de una figura
prehispánica
cómo es posible que hayas hecho esto de
una manera tan fiel
y decía es que yo sigo una técnica que
se llama focalizar el punto
ah caray cómo está eso que yo creo que
mi abuelo ya ya está ya está medio
deshabitado porque él tenía un taller de
hacer un taller para zapatos para hacer
zapatos una zapatería y de repente lo
convirtió en un taller artesanal para
hacer cosas de cerámica de barro y está
muy disparatado esto cómo es que surge
este artista después de 60 años como
estuvo guardando todo ese ímpetu y de
repente se convierte en un artista
alguien que hace mecánicamente un
calzado que está trabajando todos los
días
religiosamente para hacer su dinero y
repentinamente resulta que mi abuelo ya
es una artista
cómo está eso
lo que sucede es que bueno él tenía una
técnica que después me explico que se
llamaba focalizar el punto
dice mira yo siempre acompañé a las
personas que venían a ixtlán del río a
buscar figurillas de barro prehispánicas
ustedes saben allí hay un asentamiento
prehispánico y había una fiebre tremenda
de de extranjeros por las figuras
prehispánicas
y llegaban y las compraban y
seleccionaban y se las llevaban y
ustedes habrán de saber en la mayoría de
los museos de antropología historia del
mundo están figurillas que dice es
figura estilo islam no figure pieza de
cerámica de estilo islam entonces mi
abuelo repentinamente encontró la manera
de cambiar su taller de zapatería porque
ya venían todas las empresas esas
tremendas que el calzado pues se lo
ponía uno en un rato y éste pues ya no
necesitabas esperarte de un mes para que
mi abuelo hiciera un par de zapatos
entonces le empezaron a hacer una
competencia terrible y vio la
oportunidad de sacar al artista que él
tenía y hacer figuras prehispánicas pero
como le llaman ahorita fake
o sea fusil dijo pues estos cuates en
lugar de que se lleven las figuras
originales les voy a hacer copias no
porque él no quería que se llevaran las
figuras originales
y como él había trabajado mucho tiempo
con los arqueólogos
y tenía de memoria una multitud de
piezas entonces empezó a reproducirlas y
él dijo que su técnica era la
focalización del punto y dijo mira te
voy a explicar cómo está eso ahorita por
ejemplo piensa lo que hiciste muy
placentero este día
y tuve que confesarle que me fui por el
arroyo a la escuela que era algo
prohibido para nosotros y es que me fui
mirando los peces en el agua
transparente de los árboles las dianas
todo el paisaje los pájaros y sentí algo
muy hermoso a ver vuelve a recordar eso
y focaliza donde sentías esa emoción
donde sientes esa emoción a cara y cerré
los ojos y recordé y dije pues aquí
arriba de la oreja ahí siento esa
felicidad muy bien anótalo ese es el
punto donde tú tienes ese tipo de
felicidad yo sé que al rato ustedes van
a salir a hacer ese ejercicio es decir a
ver dónde tengo yo la felicidad entonces
bueno y dice cuando tú sientes mucho
coraje dónde dónde tienes dónde tienes
dónde se manifiesta en qué parte de tu
cuerpo se manifiesta
pues en mi puño derecho cuando sientas
frustración pues ay caramba entre mis
ojos y así dice haz un mapa corporal de
todo eso y entonces vas a saber dónde se
focaliza cada una de tus emociones
y soy yo por ejemplo para recordar
localizó en mí bueno en todos los
pueblos se dice sobre la mollera verdad
en la parte superior dice aquí yo lo
jack y yo lo focalizó entonces me
concentro en ese lugar y empiezo a
recordar de una manera automática todas
las cosas y que a caramba está muy
interesante esto no y cada uno podemos
hacer ese mapa a ustedes yo se lo van a
hacer en su casa
están saliendo de aquí van a decir ah y
voy a hacer eso que dijo el maestro
bueno entonces mi abuelo utilizar esa
técnica de focalizar el punto y
reproducir esas imágenes y todas esas
piezas llegaban muchos antropólogos
arqueólogos expertos y él vendía las
piezas es algo maravilloso no le quedaba
ninguna pero luego ya después empezaron
a hacerse muy listos y dijeron a ver
cómo está esto que este señor todas las
piezas son originales
y ya utilizaron una técnica que era
ponerle saliva a la pieza
es sencillo si se evaporaba rápidamente
es que la pieza era nueva y si la saliva
quedaba si permanecía entonces quería
decir que la pieza si era original y
pues no pues toda la se evaporaba no ya
no le compraban piezas y me decía mi
abuelo ándale muchacho ponte escucha lo
que dicen estos señores y dije caramba
entonces tuve que empezar a aprender a
hablar un poco a escuchar inglés por la
radio y aprender un poco y ya le dije a
mi abuelo oiga pues el truco está así lo
que sucede es que estos señores ya
encontraron la manera de saber cuál es
una pieza original y cuál no
y todo eso yo lo aprendí ahí en el
taller del abuelo
a manipular el barro y todas esas cosas
filosóficas que me enseñaban
y entonces ya le dije abuelo lo que pasa
es que
la humedad hace esto y se trasmina y ya
dijo ah bueno van a ver y como él había
sido fabricantes de calzado entonces les
puso grasa a los monitos esos los
enterró los saco no le ponían saliva y
saliva y apartaban todos los más nuevos
esto no muy bueno muy mucho puede no
decir y compraban todos los monitos no
y ya esté mi abuelo volvió otra vez con
su boyante negocio de hacer monos y
ahora su ayudante ayudante también que
empezaba a sentir cómo hacer esas copias
como cómo hacer esos monitos y me decía
mira a mi hijo lo que pasa es que en
este mundo necesitamos sentir las cosas
para crecer lo que sucede es que ya
estamos llenos de palabras estamos
llenos de textos las palabras fueron
después de las emociones
si primero fueron las emociones cuando
los primeros seres racionales cuando
miraron una hermosa puesta de sol no lo
tradujeron en palabras ni en frases ni
nada de eso simplemente lo sintieron fue
una emoción
y así se fueron llenando de emociones
ese es el ser humano primario primitivo
está hecho de emociones y las hemos ido
perdiendo a través del tiempo por eso es
que a nosotros les damos consejos a los
hijos mira te va a pasar esto y es del
otro y hay puros consejos de viejito no
hasta que sucede una cosa entonces ya
hay caramba por qué por qué hasta que ya
tienen la sensación de lo que se les
dijo entonces ya aprenden
y yo cuando llegué a la escuela primaria
pensé que iba a haber una materia que
refiriera a la cuestión de las
sensaciones de sentir que nos iban a
decir muchachos ahora tenemos
matemáticas biología y sensaciones
macará y verdad emociones pero no
sucedió eso llegué y luego 2 por 12 2
por 2 4 y aprendes de la rápido y se
acabó todo pero nunca nos dijeron a ver
asómate a la ventana mira ese niño que
está allí que tiene mucho calor que
estás con su mamá que no tiene quien le
dé de comer cierra los ojos imagina que
tu eres él
nunca me dijeron eso o sea nunca nos
enseñaron a tener empatía ni nada de eso
no sea nuestro mundo fue muy diferente
díaz y aprender cosas y todo y ahorita
todavía con los medios de comunicación
es más estamos bombardeados de
información y de información y nunca
tenemos un espacio para nosotros un
momento una burbuja de silencio en donde
podamos recogernos un rato con nosotros
mismos y decir qué sentido oí que sentí
hoy
porque llega así como te fue en la
escuela como te fue
pero no que sentiste hoy qué emociones
tuviste hoy no es lo que hacen al ser
humano más profundo y eso es lo que nos
ha fallado
y bueno mi abuelo pues hacía entre otras
barbaridades también dibujaban dibujaba
con el papel del pan bueno mi abuela
quería siempre que hubiera dinero ella
traía su delantal para las moneditas las
monedas y los billetes y todos los
billetes entonces mi abuela ella llegaba
y decía cuánto fue ahora de edad de
ganancia pero nunca ella le preguntaba
oye qué emociones tuviste cómo te fue
con la escultura etcétera no y bueno
entonces mi abuelo para
calmar sus ansias de dibujante lo que
hacía era cuando terminaba la cena
tomaba el papel donde se envolvía el pan
y veía todo eso
lo que dejaba la manteca y lo iba
siguiendo con un lápiz y luego lo
palpaba las arrugas y todo eso y hacía
otras texturas iba guardando sus papeles
y después los pegaba en un gran gran 9
panel que le ponía cuerdas y sabe que
tanto para que no sé desvencijar a cómo
podía y en mi educación me llamó y me
dijo ven muchacho ven qué pasó abuelo
estaba muy excitado qué pasó me dijo es
que encontré la manera de pintar la
música mira y le daba con la brocha y
las cuerdas esas vibraban y aventaban
esta pintura por todos lados y dijo
estoy pintando la música
y bueno les tengo que decir ahora por
primera vez que mi abuelo fue el que
inventó cómo pintar la música pero nunca
he visto un libro que le reconozca eso
no pero él fue
y bueno paralelamente con mi abuelo que
fue mi primer este maestro paralelamente
había un pintor que llegó a instan del
río quería irse la apuesta ganar fortuna
hacerse famoso
y todo eso iba con un hermano que era
doctor y le dijo de su hermano mira
hermano 20 conmigo a tijuana porque en
tijuana vamos a hacer fortuna
allá te compran el arte los doctores
ganan mucho va mucho turismo mucho
norteamericano y todo eso te vas conmigo
y vamos a hacer dinero pero él
había perdido a su novia la amaba
demasiado hasta la locura y él no quería
alejarse mucho de guadalajara y cuando
iban pasando por island dijo aquí me
quedo
así de una manera abrupta y fortuita se
quedó en ixtlán
entonces murió él fue mi vecino no vi
que su casa se empezó a llenar de blanco
pintó las paredes de blanco pues cuando
vine aquí dije no será la casa deja sin
tu jiménez porque también aquí está todo
de blanco no
y pintó sus sus paneles usted las todo
de blanco el vestido de blanco y a
pintar porque él se iba a ser famoso y
la novia algún día lo ido a ver en los
periódicos y lo iba y va a recobrar ese
amor no
porque él había sido amigo de un gran
pintor que se llamaba ustedes han de
saber gonzález camarena fue un muralista
y su mural se en chile y todo eso y él
fue compañero de él y me decía mira
verdad que yo pinto mejor que este cuate
y yo pues tenía que decirle que sí
porque si no como si usted pinta mejor y
pintaba desnudos y pintaba esas cosas
este
tremendas tan fantasmagóricas que la
gente no entendía pasaba por su casa y
decía este señor está loco qué es lo que
está pintando aquí y además el pintaba
nada más con short cuando en ixtlán del
río no se podía ni siquiera ver las
piernas de nadie ni de las gallinas
entonces este sí y ya pasaba la gente a
la iglesia por ahí y le dijeron oiga
señor este es un pueblo de dios usted
está pintando desnudos y está pintando
también tú semidesnudo qué es eso o no
y él dijo que entonces que hago pues le
vamos a quitar que ya no le rentan aquí
o cierra sus puertas para que nadie
observe para que nadie vea entonces lo
condenaron a la soledad y a la oscuridad
y yo veía ese pintor sea todo ese
sufrimiento todo ese proceso de un
artista decía caramba es tan difícil ser
artista es tan difícil ser ser pintor
manifestarse de una manera libre si
paralelamente parece que así es en la
vida cotidiana no manifestarse de una
manera libre es algo terrible es algo
tremendo y bueno el pintor cerró sus
puertas y todo eso se puso a pintar lo
que él quería pero empezó a beber
alcohol hizo se deprimió y falleció pues
solo y con una muchacha que pues que le
encargaron ahí para que viviera con él
al final ella fue su mujer y cuando ya
estaba muriendo
comprendió al final que su verdadero
amor había sido esa mujer con la que
vivió no porque la tomó de la mano y
miramos como se despidió de ella no tuvo
que haber traspasado todo es tiempo de
hacer su arte de desarrollar sus
impulsos y todo eso a través de la
pintura que lo utilizaba que llamaba
veladuras que son materiales espesos
donde ponía un poquito de color para y
con las manos embarrada eso para que la
luz atrás minará y el papel no fuera
únicamente una cosa plana sino que fuera
tridimensional y poder ver una realidad
más compleja y más completa no y todo
eso lo encontró por el amor y la pasión
que tenía por alguien y finalmente pues
ese alguien fue la persona con la que
vivió
bueno ahora quiero referirme un poco a
mí cuando ya después de ese pintor tuve
la oportunidad de empezar a pintar pues
pintaba solamente en blanco y negro
porque una terrible depresión me abatió
pero recordé a mi abuelo que decía
focalizar el punto entonces yo dije a
ver dónde siento la depresión la
depresión la sentía en la garganta en
los dos lados de la garganta y decía
bueno aquí están los focos prendidos
pero yo tengo el foco de la alegría de
este lado tengo el foco de la voz e de
ir a algún lugar hermoso de este lado
tengo la voluntad acá tengo o sea todos
esos focos los prendí y trate de
avasallar al otro
o sea un incendio contra el otro
incendio porque ya mi depresión era un
terrible incendio y tuve que aprender
todas esas luces para luchar y
finalmente derrotar la depresión y es
algo increíble dije a cara y mi abuelo
tenía razón no es que hay que batallar a
la depresión con los otros focos que
tenemos y todo el mundo puede porque son
más grandes son son enormemente más
grandes que los otros y ahí fue cuando
finalmente me di cuenta que
mi abuelo tenía razón y bueno pues de
ahí salté al color de ahí salté al color
cuando la depresión termina y aquí
tenemos un colorido hermoso el colorido
wirrárika y hoy justamente estoy
haciendo una exposición en los ángeles
pero preferí estar aquí una exposición
donde participa sergio arau el que hizo
la película un día sin mexicanos estamos
ahí en los ángeles california sin
default ahí tenemos una exposición de
pintura y voy terminando un mural muy
colorido en los ángeles también que es
un mural en un lugar muy icónico de los
eeuu el hospital general de los ángeles
ahí va a estar un mural mío se exhibe a
partir de diciembre en los ángeles no y
otro personaje que me marcó fue un mago
el mago corona ese mago a través de 20
años lo entrevisté hice un libro que se
llama
el sueño del mago que también deja sus
enseñanzas el aparte de desaparecer
cosas y todo eso de hacer trucos también
aparece cosas en la persona con la que
platica y eso es muy importante no dejar
una huella con quienes tenemos un trato
tratar de inyectarle emociones sentir
para crecer muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]